the three beat weave is a classic of the
PO world for many people it's the first
trick they ever learned and today I'm
going to share with you my five favorite
variations on this
trick Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
give you five different types of weaves
that are going to blow your mind and
Amaze your friends but before we dive in
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark bunk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrro teror light
toys spinballs and Ultra poy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- buus
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission now if you're
familiar with POI at all you have
absolutely seen somebody performing a
weave in some way shape or form weaves
involve carrying the poy back and forth
across our body in a variety of
different ways they're the trick that
inspired me to pick up PO in the first
place and I'm sure I'm not the only one
and I think that weave sometimes get a
bad rap because they're so associated
with the beginner level of poy spinning
that a lot of people just forget about
them as they move on through their POI
Journey and I think that that's a
mistake cuz there's a lot to explore
here and a lot of things that you might
not even think of when we bring up the
word weaves so in this video I'm going
to share with you five of my favorites
that utilize this concept and I hope
you'll either discover something new
that'll be a great challenge for you or
connect some dots and realize that
something that you had taken for granted
actually fits into this world too and
now without further
Ado trick number one the three beat
weave so yeah this this is the trick
that we all know and love and that was
the goal for many of us when we first
started up our spinning anyway you slice
it this move is an absolute classic that
never gets old and never loses its style
anybody who picks up POI at some point
is going to learn it and I honestly have
to say that I sometimes take issue with
how this move is positioned because a
lot of people kind of throw it at
beginners and say here this is one of
the first things that you should learn
and I think that there's a lot going on
there and it kind of turns into a way
bigger hurdle for a beginner to get over
than they really need to at the
beginning of their Journey after all
getting down this trick involves getting
down a solid split Time same direction
feel with your POI being able to switch
the POI back and forth across your body
in a Tic Tac and adding that extra beat
on your non-native side to be able to
pass one hand over the other and repeat
this pattern all in all there's actually
a lot here that is deceptively difficult
to have to get through all that said it
also can't be denied that this move
functions more or less as a stepping
stone to get you to other stuff
including trick number two the Archer
weave so it's funny to put this move on
the list cuz it's essentially the exact
same move as the last one that we
covered and yet such a minor tweak
creates such a visually powerful
difference between the two after all the
Archer weave is exactly the same pattern
as the 3B weave we're just extending one
arm out completely away from our
shoulder and holding the other one very
close to that same shoulder and yet some
something about that just makes the move
looks like something completely
different and Incredibly captivating it
has to be said that it actually looks so
different that when I first tried
learning this move I assumed that it
required a whole bunch of skills that I
didn't have it took years for me to
realize no actually it's the exact same
move just presented in a different way
bonus points too because this move is
also one of the very first body tracers
that many people learn I also have to
say that transitioning it into an Archer
weave Fountain is one of my absolute
favorite things to do in the PO world
ever so we're going to chalk this down
as a whole lot of win I hope you agree
okay so now I've given you what
essentially are two kind of vanilla uses
of the three beat weave so it's time to
start getting a little bit exotic trick
number three the alien
weave so straight up this is one of
those weird techy things that alien John
created back in the day that many of us
barely comprehended at the time and
looking back on it also realized it's
like wow there was kind of a lot going
on there essentially what this move is
is realizing that you can add and
subtract beats to each side of a weave
such that you're doing what looks like a
5 beat weave on one side and a two beat
weave on the other side and miraculously
winding up with a total of three down
beats in the process this move totally
fits all the requirements of a 3 beat
weave in that there's a total of three
down beats for each poy as well as the
fact that you're switching up which hand
is leading on each side it just so
happens to be that you're doing it by
adding two degrees of Twist on one side
and having Zer degrees of twist on the
other I have to say I also think that
this is just a great exercise for
getting to a 5B weave because you can
work your way up to adding that extra
degree of twist on each side
individually before adding the extra
degree of twist on both sides all that
said this is also an excellent bit of
theory that reminds us that what we
think of as a 3B weave might be a little
bit deceptive and also a little bit more
complicated than we think all right so
now that we've played around with the
idea of adding beats to particular sides
of a weave there is another stop we have
to make that is absolutely unavoidable
and it's actually going to involve
subtracting hands rather than adding
positions with them trick number four
the meteor 3B
weave so yeah we're not in Kansas
anymore we're still doing three beat
weaves but now we have kind of radically
reimagined what that actually means just
like when we were playing around with
the alien weave meteor weaves also give
us the opportunity to add and subract
Beats to each side in this case normally
when we perform a forwards weave with
our meteors we're doing a Thum Le two
beat but we can just as easily add an
extra bead on one side to make one side
of it Pinky lead instead and this gives
us all the qualities we need to get a 3B
weave I'm not going to say that this is
the prettiest thing that we have on this
list though it is really useful in
creating flowers with meteors but at the
same time it's good to know that we can
extend the idea even into meteor world
and just like the alien weave this is an
excellent exercise for controlling the
number of Beats we have on each side of
our meteor weaves see if you prefer
adding in that pinky lead side on either
your backside or your front side I'm
really curious so real quickly before I
share with you the final trick on my
list for those of you out there that are
still working on some of the lower tier
tricks on this list I have a resource
that will probably be helpful to you the
flow circle is a weekly exclusive lesson
that is available only to my patreon
supporters this month I'm focusing on
three beat weaves and specifically on
the performance potential of them the
first lesson is already up and it covers
how to explore volume with 3 beat weaves
in future weeks we're also going to be
covering things like how to add and
subtract beads to each side make sure to
go sign up for that now over at
patreon.com Drex Factor poy and now my
final pick for my top five favorite
three beat weaves of all time is trick
number five the isolated 3B
weave okay so if there's a version of
the 3B weave that c comes with the hard
mode dialed up all the way this is
definitely it isolations are challenging
enough in and of themselves but
performing them in such a way that you
can perform a three beat weave with them
oh my goodness this one took me years to
learn I remember hearing about people
performing this weave back in the day
and I finally saw it demonstrated in the
Arizona transmission video that xan
Moore and alien John did many many years
ago I made it a goal to learn each and
every trick in that video and you know
what this one was the last one that I
got still to this day I barely ever see
this trick performed and with good
reason it's a huge challenge but you
know what it is also a challenge that
rewards those who go to seek it because
you learn a lot of really awesome skills
in the process and that's why it is my
top pick for my favorite three beat
weave of all time what did you think of
my list are there any variations on the
three beat weave that I left out that
would have been on your list leave me a
comment and let me know
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission and if you all out there
watching also want to sign up to support
my work well there's an easy way to do
that head on on over to patreon and sign
up at
patreon.com Factor pooy there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you're struggling with
a topic we didn't talk about in this
video namely doing reverse 3 beat WIS
I've got an entire video that'll break
it down for you in a bunch of really
easy to understand exercises I'll go
ahead and link to that video down in the
description as well as up here on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and Float yourselves today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace